investigations which were described as
inadequate
well among those hoping to get answers
this morning is the reverend charlotte
cheshire whose son adam has been left
with multiple health problems let's go
to donna ockendon now in that press
conference
maternity services at the shrewsbury and
telford hospital nhs trust
my name is donna
donna ockendon and i am the chair of
this independent review
before we start formally today i would
like to pay tribute to the families
whose voices and stories are central to
this review of maternity services
what happened to you
and your families
your babies your wives
your daughters your sisters and your
partners
really matters
and those experiences will ensure safe
maternity care for all going forward
leading this maternity review has been
the biggest privilege of my life
it will remain with me forever
and i would like to thank all of the
families
for the trust that they have put
in my team and i
the families have asked me to thank the
many journalists gathered here today
they have told me how important a role
many of you have played in getting their
voices and stories heard
they have asked me to thank you all for
your professionalism
and your kindness they have told me that
some of you cried along with them on
hearing the accounts of what happened to
them
your support has been so important to
them and thank you on behalf of the
families
in these circumstances and in this place
there are families who have bravely
decided to attend and i know that you
will understand that they have a
reasonable expectation of privacy so may
i ask all of you as journalists
particularly as far as photography is
concerned
to please wait to be approached by
families thank you so much for
understanding
today i also wanted to pay tribute to my
wonderful clinical review team
since the review started we have had
more than 90 midwives and doctors
working within this review
ensuring that the report you read today
is underpinned by hundreds of years of
combined midwifery and medical expertise
in delivering safe maternity care
thank you
the last two years have been the
toughest in memory for our nhs
at a time when the pressures of kovid 19
have been unrelenting and teams
including maternity teams have been
stretched beyond all expectations
maternity services along with their
other nhs colleagues tell me they are
exhausted
our nhs has endeavoured to give of its
very best looking at how it can deliver
services in new ways to provide the best
quality care for its patients
we are right to be proud of our nhs and
staff that have given so much of
themselves over this time
but today i'm here to describe a
different scenario i am here to talk to
you about the shrewsbury and telford
hospital nhs trust
a trust whose maternity services failed
both families across shropshire and
sometimes their own staff over a
prolonged period of time
this final report follows on from our
first report which was published in
december 2020
in the first report we outlined the
local actions for learning and immediate
and essential actions to be implemented
at the trust and across the wider
maternity system in england
this second and final report builds upon
our first report all the local actions
and immediate and essential actions
within our first report remain important
and must be progressed
for this second report my independent
maternity review team have identified a
number of new themes which we believe
must now be shared across all maternity
services in england as a matter of
urgency to bring about essential change
which will in turn improve safety
from our review of all cases that make
up this final report we identify four
key pillars to drive forward
improvements in maternity services
at the shrewsbury telford hospital nhs
trust and all other trusts across
england
these are
safe staffing levels properly funded
a well-trained workforce
learning from incidents
and listening to families
whilst progress has been made in some of
these areas there must now be a fully
funded
and then concerted effort by all nhs
trusts across england to ensure that
these four pillars are the foundation
the roadmap and the blueprint of all
maternity services going forward
since the publication of our first
report the government has introduced a
range of measures and invested very
significantly in maternity and neonatal
services across the country
this includes 127 million pounds of
funding announced last week
much of this funding is for workforce
expansion improving training and
improving culture in maternity services
nhs providers as cited in the recent
health select committee report has
estimated the cost of full expansion of
maternity services workforce to be
between 200 million and 350 million
which is significantly more than has
already been committed
we the independent maternity review team
fully endorse and support this view
our final report spans the period from
2000 to 2019
however we are deeply concerned that
families continue to contact the review
team in 2020 and 2021 raising concerns
about the safety of maternity care they
have received at the shrewsbury and
telford hospital nhs trust
some of these recent families contacted
us with reports they wanted to share
with us we haven't been able to include
them fully within the review but what we
have seen is that the themes within
their reports seem to echo concerns we
have previously seen during this review
seeing these repeated themes is a cause
for grave concern
it is clear that there are a number of
areas of maternity care where the
shrewsbury and telford hospital nhs
trust still has significant learning to
undertake
as you may know this review was
commissioned by nhs improvement at the
request of the then secretary of state
for health and social care jeremy hunt
mp in 2017
the number of cases within this review
grew from 23 and then to more than a
thousand families
it has previously been reported that
this review was considering 1862
family cases
however after removing duplication of
recording and excluding cases where they
were unavailable hospital records or we
could not get family consent for
participation the final number of
families now included is 1486.
some families had multiple clinical
incidents therefore a total of 1500
clinical incidents involving mothers and
babies have been reviewed
this includes a very early case from
1973
and the latest case from 2020.
we now know that this is a trust that
failed to investigate
failed to learn
and failed to improve
this resulted in tragedies and
life-changing incidents for so many of
our families
our team have reviewed all clinical
cases
where we have found good practice we
have said that clearly in the report
however my review team is concerned at
the significant number of cases that
fall into categories two and three
these are cases graded as having
significant category two or major
concerns category three in the maternity
care provided
when reviewing the stillbirths and
neonatal deaths in the time period 2011
to 2019
the review team found that 40
of the stillbirths reviewed by us did
not have a trust investigation
in the same period 43
of the neonatal deaths reviewed by us
had not had a trust investigation
you will all know
that without investigation we cannot
understand what may have gone wrong and
we cannot learn
without learning we cannot improve
maternity care for the future
i would now like to talk you through a
timeline of some events at the trust and
clearly this is described in greater
detail in the report
today and with permission of our parents
i would first like to tell you about
baby olivia who died shortly after her
birth in 2002.
her mum repeatedly tried to raise
concerns about failings at the trust
hoping someone would do something
four years after olivia's death in 2006
her mum went on the this morning show
olivia's mom told me that over all those
years raising concerns she felt like a
lone voice in the wind
at the same time as olivia's mum was
appearing on tv
other families also suffered the deaths
of their babies and only then did the
health care commission review the trust
it failed to take the necessary action
this was a missed opportunity for the
trust to learn the external scrutiny of
the trust had clearly failed and this is
a theme that has been repeated again and
again over many years
so many parents have told us they tried
to raise concerns but they were not
listened to
eventually through the tremendous
achievements of rhiannon davis and
richard stanton and kaylee and colin
griffis following the deaths of their
daughters kate and pippa
kate in 2009 and then pippa in 2016 the
required scrutiny has now taken place
the voices of families are now finally
being heard
our team want to highlight that in the
eight months before baby kate died there
were two other incidents at the trust
where babies also lost their lives
these babies have been named in our
report and will be named today with the
permission of their parents
they were called baby joshua
and baby thomas
in the case of baby joshua in 2008
almost identical mistakes were made in
his mother's care and in his care as
those that were made in the care and
treatment of baby kate and her mother
rhiannon
with baby thomas in 2009 there were
gross failings in the care provided and
yet the trust did not tell the truth to
the family
the review team is particularly
concerned by the lack of transparency
internally within the trust as well as
the lack of honesty and transparency
shown to families
this is all the more concerning when it
is clear that major issues in safety
were apparent in both midwifery-led unit
and consultant settings during the
period leading up to the birth and death
of kate stanton davis and before her the
birth and death of baby joshua and then
baby thomas
unfortunately these cases were not
isolated incidents and through the time
span of our review we have found
repeated errors in care which led to
injury to either mothers or their babies
we have fully reviewed the cases of 12
mothers who lost their lives giving
birth at the trust
75
of the cases of maternal death have been
graded by our team as categories two and
three with significant or major concerns
in the care provided
unfortunately and overall our report
describes that a significant number of
mothers and babies received care that
fell way below the standards expected
and this continued throughout the whole
period of the review
the review team has also found evidence
of significant under-reporting and cases
that should have been investigated and
were not
during the period this review looks at
we are aware of eight external bodies
who inspected visited assessed or
checked upon the trust
this was a trust with significant
problems and whilst independent and
external reports often indicated that
the maternity service should improve its
governance and investigatory procedures
this did not happen
the trust was of the belief that its
maternity services were good
they were wrong
the trust's executive team and board had
continual change in churn over the
period of this review with multiple
different board chairs and chief
executives over the time period we
considered
this constant change led to an inability
to deliver service improvement the trust
board didn't have oversight and didn't
have a full understanding of the issues
and concerns within maternity services
this resulted in a lack of strategic
direction no effective change and the no
development of accountable
implementation plans
our consideration of clinical governance
processes and documents at the trust has
shown that investigatory processes were
not followed to a standard that would
have been expected for the particular
time the incident occurred
unfortunately the review believes
failings have persisted in some
investigations as late as 2019 in the
cases we considered as part of this
review
although independent and external
reports consistently indicated that the
maternity service should improve its
procedures governance and investigatory
this message was lost in a trust
excuse me which was struggling with
other concerns
this meant that consistently throughout
the review period lessons were not
learned mistakes and care were repeated
and the safety of mothers and babies was
unnecessarily compromised as a result
we spoke to staff members at the trust
and documentary evidence also considered
by the review team showed us that
following serious incidents there would
be no follow-up from recommendations
made
one staff member told us this wasn't
just a maternity unit in chaos and under
pressure this was a whole organization
where it was difficult to find an area
which was not under pressure
another member of staff told us there
was a republic of maternity where often
the maternity service seemed to consume
its own smoke and didn't like having
oversight by the corporate team
we are very concerned that in very
recent weeks staff currently working at
the trust have contacted the review team
to express their concerns about
maternity services at the trust in the
here and now staff have described to us
that they were frightened to speak to
the maternity review team and were
advised by trust managers not to
participate in the staff voices
initiative
one staff member said to us and this is
a message for the families
i am sorry
and i know that sorry is not enough
but by engaging with this review
we hope that our voices will finally be
acknowledged and that change will happen
so that there are robust and independent
places for clinicians to speak out that
acknowledge what we are saying
what needs changing and that we act on
this without fearing reprisals
another said to us very recently and by
very recently i mean march 2022
if i could say anything to the families
it would be that they were people who
tried to make changes we tried to
escalate our concerns and be heard but
every process we used was set up not to
acknowledge our voices or the problems
we were highlighting we were ignored and
made out to be the problem but
ultimately we failed to make ourselves
heard
i'm now going to turn to page 184
in the report
because i'd like to share with you
just a couple of
things that staff have told us in recent
weeks and in fact this
was added to the report in the very
final days before printing
section 1.32 will tell you
how staff members described a clique on
the labour ward at the trust with a
culture of undermining and bullying
staff members described that this had
negatively and seriously affected their
mental health other staff members
described that the behavior experienced
on the labour ward was so bad that they
had difficulty finishing their shifts
and cried secretly whilst in work
these staff declined for their direct
quotes to be used
because they were fearful of being
identified and section 1.35 on page 184
says
a current staff member in maternity
services at the trust spoke to the
review team in early 22 2022 but
described themselves as fearful to do so
the staff member said i really had to
think very carefully about approaching
the staff voices that's us when we were
told not to speak out but i will do it
and take the consequences because it is
the right thing to do
i am clear that there is no support
for those that speak up
the trust has more than 60 actions local
actions for learning arising from this
final report
our review team examined every area of
maternity care at the trust including
antenatal intrapartum labour postnatal
neonatal mothers who have died and
obstetric anesthesia and found that
improvements were needed with staffing
levels training investigations and
learning as well as listening to
families
in addition we have actions for
governance of maternity services at the
trust as well as how it supports
families particularly the bereaved
in addition the trust must improve how
it supports its own staff and ensures
that staff can raise concerns without
fear of reprisals
the trust must also ensure they continue
to make progress on the local actions
for learning and immediate and essential
actions from report one
this is a trust with a significant
amount of work to do to continually
improve the safety of maternity care
with their own staff coming forward in
the last few weeks to tell me they
wanted assurance that the trust would
still be monitored very closely and that
in the words of a current member of
staff the trust must show real evidence
of change not just say in the press they
have changed
some of the key local actions for
learning and they are of course included
in more detail in the report
incidents must be graded appropriately
with the level of harm recorded as the
level of harm the patient actually
suffered
correct investigation processes
procedures and terminology
must be used in line with the relevant
nhs serious incident framework
all investigations must be undertaken by
a multi-professional team of
investigators and never by one
individual or a single profession
in view of the relatively high number of
direct maternal deaths the trust's
current mandatory
multidisciplinary team training for
common obstetric emergencies must be
reviewed in partnership with a
neighbouring tertiary unit to ensure
that training is fit for purpose
the trust must adopt a consistent and
systematic approach to risk assessment
at booking and throughout pregnancy to
ensure women are supported effectively
and referred to specialist services
where required
all clinicians at the trust must work
towards establishing a compassionate
culture where staff learn together
rather than apportioning blame
staff must be encouraged to speak out
when they have concerns about care
can i please stress these are not nice
to haves or maybes these are must do's
it is recognized that many of the issues
highlighted in this report are not
unique to shrewsbury and helford
hospital nhs trust and they have been
highlighted in national reports into
maternity services in recent years
this is why the review team has also
identified 15 immediate and essential
actions which must be implemented by all
trusts in england providing maternity
services
these are focused on workforce funding
planning and sustainability safe
staffing escalation and accountability
leadership
investigations of incidents and
complaint handling
learning from the deaths of mothers
multidisciplinary training complex
antenatal care pre-term labour and birth
at term obstetric anesthesia postnatal
care bereavement care neonatal care and
supporting families
what is essential is that the process of
investigation learning and service
change from maternity incidents is
independently chaired and changes must
be introduced into clinical practice
within six months of an incident
occurring
no longer should families have to chase
for the results of investigations that
is not your job to do there must be a
reasonable time frame on learning and
practice change
with uh when clinical incidents occur
it is absolutely clear that there is an
urgent need for a robust and funded
england-wide maternity workforce plan
starting right now without delay and
continuing over multiple years
this is essential to address the present
and future requirements for midwives
obstetricians anaesthetists neonatal
teams and equipment and all the
associated staff working in and around
maternity services
without this very significant multi-year
investment maternity services cannot
provide safe and effective care for
women and babies
this plan must also focus on
significantly reducing the attrition of
midwives and doctors those who leave
since increases in workforce numbers are
of limited use if those already within
the workforce continue to leave
this is best explained as you can't fill
a bath with the plug out clearly if
midwives and doctors continue to leave
our maternity services and we do not
improve working conditions for maternity
teams there is very little benefit in
continually recruiting more staff
to harness the learning from this report
and bring together other learnings from
across the maternity system a working
group independent of the maternity
transformation program that has joint
royal college leadership including
midwives and obstetrics and gynecology
anaesthetist the obstetric anesthetist
association plus pediatrics and child
health must now be set up
the remit of this group must be to guide
the maternity transformation program
around implementation of our iea's
immediate and essential actions
and the recommendations of other reports
currently being prepared
this investment and work must be
progressed at pace and continued for as
long as necessary to ensure that no
other family experiences the many
tragedies described in our report
only with a robustly funded well-staffed
and well-trained workforce can families
and government be able to expect
consistent delivery of safe and
compassionate maternity care locally and
across england
thank you for listening to me today
thank you
[Applause]
well donna rockington then delivering
the results of her report that had been
carried out into the deaths of babies
and mums
at this hospital trust shrewsbury
hospital trust
where
201
babies and nine mothers
died as a result of what went wrong
there uh sky's becky johnson has been
following this story for us um
a lot of criticism in in this report but
it's like dancing around what is
possibly the central issue which is that
there was a keenness for mums to have
natural births and essentially
medical intervention when it came seemed
to often come too late
yes and i have a copy of the full report
234 pages of devastating analysis of
what was going on at this trust for more
than two decades and within this report
there are testimonies from staff members
who talk about how they felt that they
should always avoid doing caesareans how
the trust was proud of its low rate of
caesarean sections and indeed donna
ockendon
in some other comments that she's given
on publication of this report has said
that in some cases uh
where a caesarean uh wasn't given um if
if the trust had indeed intervened had
indeed uh given a mother a cesarean
section babies could have lived so this
is one of the causes of some of these
deaths at the trust but there were
multiple failings as donna ockendon has
been outlining this was a trust that
failed over many years to learn from
mistakes they failed to properly risk
assess mothers they failed to listen to
the concerns of mothers
and then when babies died they would
blame the mothers for their own baby's
deaths donna ockendon said that this
failure in care carried on for a
prolonged period of time she talked
about staff having told her that they
felt that they could not
speak up within the trust that they
tried to raise concerns but that they
were simply unable to staff who would
cry on shift because of what was going
on
in this trust but we know from her
report that initially when she was asked
to investigate back in 2017 there were
23 cases highlighted as being of concern
now over the years since she's been
investigating so many
families contacted her that in fact the
testimonies of 1486
families went into this report and she's
concluded from the cases that she looked
at
210 deaths could have been avoided that
includes 201 deaths of babies
131 stillbirths could have been avoided
70 neonatal deaths could have been
avoided and also the deaths of nine
mothers could have been avoided if only
better care had been provided at this
trust the report also details how 94 uh
babies are now living with long-term
brain damage or cerebral palsy as a
result
of the failures in care at this trust
and don okanden said that her report
primarily looks at the period between
the year 2000 and 2019 but she said
she's deeply concerned that her team are
still being contacted by families who
are receiving poor care now
babies still dying
up until very recently at this trust
this is not
something that is in the past she said
she's concerned about what is still
going on and she has set out a whole
series of things that both this trust
and maternity units right across the
country need to do
to improve safety it includes better
monitoring of babies it includes more
wardrobes by doctors it includes
listening when things go wrong learning
when things go wrong now we have had
some reaction to this report from the
health secretary sajid javid and i'll
read you his response now
he says donna ockendon's report
paints a tragic and harrowing picture of
repeated failures in care over two
decades and i am deeply sorry to all the
families who've suffered so greatly
since the initial report was published
in 2020 we've taken steps to invest in
maternity services and grow the
workforce and we'll make the changes
that are needed so that no families have
to go through this pain again i would
like to thank donna okanden and her
whole team for their work throughout
this long and distressing inquiry
as well as all the families who came
forward to tell their stories
donna ockendon was at pains to thank
those families it is only due to them
really having to shout to be heard that
we know about what was going on at this
trust because over many years there were
attempts made within the trust to
silence those families but they refused
to believe that their babies had to die
and now we know the true extent of what
was going on at this trust we'll be
getting reaction from all those families
you heard them applaud donna ockendon as
she delivered her report for them this
is a very big moment they want the
legacy for their babies to be
improvements in maternity care right
across the country
absolutely becky thank you so much for
summarizing the findings there well as
becky said we are expecting to get
reaction from some of the families
affected by the trust failings after
that report but before it was published
this morning reverend charlotte cheshire
spoke to sky news her son adam has been
left with multiple health problems and
she says things could and should have
been done differently
i had a full-term
pregnancy and birth my son was born at
39 weeks five so in principle everything
should have been okay
the problem was that my waters broke 35
hours before he was actually delivered
and during the next
uh 12 hours or so the staff i believe
didn't pick up on the many signs that
adam had become infected with group b
strep meningitis
and ultimately the day after his birth
he was taken to neonatal intensive care
where his entire body shut down he
stopped breathing he was blue he
suffered constant seizures he was
ultimately put into an induced coma and
on life support and nobody believed he
would live
to make a long story slightly shorter he
did survive he is in the next room next
to me i